bonjour douglas y est c'est merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france joe biden veut doubler son
objectif de vaccination aux tic au vide
pour ses 100 premiers jours
réaliste ou faisable oui en fait à
l'après roumanoff qu'il pourrait
dépasser même c'est taux de vaccination
en partie parce qu'il ya une
coordination nationale est en partie
parce qu'on a autorisé plusieurs types
les spécialistes médicale et administré
des vaccins comme les d'être enyele les
dentistes
donc oui il va arriver à sept chiffres
joe biden s'est d'ores et déjà déclaré
candidat à l'élection présidentielle de
2000 24 il aura 82 ans n'est pas un peu
prématuré sachant que son mandat vient à
peine de commencer puisque s'est pas
déplacée aussi sachant que des millions
d'américains se retrouvent au chômage à
cause de la crise sanitaire et d'autres
priorités non plutôt que de parler de
ses ambitions personnelles
oui oui la campagne permanente est
devenu un aspect de la politique
américaine comme le politique la
campagne médiatique et les promesses non
tenues
mais c'est une campagne en permanence et
en à vienne près de quatre ans de
campagne mais c'est assumant son calidad
c'est plutôt entre les deux parties
donc le champ de bataille c'est un dans
le congrès dans les étapes sur la
frontière avec le mexique est en partie
de ça c'est la campagne présidentielle
joe biden qui participent au conseil
européen qu'est ce que ça sous-entend
dans les relations transatlantiques
entre les états unis et l'union
européenne c'est l'ombre de washington
qui plane à nouveau sur bruxelles oui à
l'objective c de résoudre le le alliance
transatlantique
anthony blinken le nouvel ministère des
affaires étrangères a déjà se présenter
entre russell et c'est lui un grande
expérience de la politique américaine et
européenne
son premier livre à l'ail est ce le
sujet des oléoducs hausse pendant les
années
gan et maintenant ils trouvent pas tous
les problèmes
isolation isolation protectionnisme le
problème de budget de autant mais en
plus haut lieu d'och donnent ce crime
qui présente une faille dans l'alliance
transatlantique entre les états unis qui
veulent empêcher cet oléoduc et
allemande qui veut construire complet
tirs sur la chine a également joe biden
s'est exprimé il a insisté sur le
respect du droit international la
semaine dernière on savait que ce sujet
a créé des tensions et une rencontre
entre diplomates chinois et américains
en alaska selon vous à quoi vont
ressembler ces prochains jours au niveau
des relations washington pékin je crois
que sheen avait une sorte de carte
blanche
parce que depuis quatre ans le sujet est
toujours l'économie des échanges
commerciales
les tarifs les sanctions et maintenant
le sujet des droits humaines étaient sur
le table encore ils savent de sa pause
ça pose une difficulté pour la chine en
présentant encore en tant que nouvel
ordre mondial parce que les démocraties
n'aime pas cette histoire des
persécutions anti bête en maintenant le
parti ouest de la chine
mais après cet échange des commentaires
très porteuse je prends ce sera le
business comme normal autre question au
niveau de la politique extérieure des
états unis sur le retrait des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan
le président américain a indiqué qu'il
serait difficile de tenir l'échéance du
1er mai cette déclaration intervient
alors que les états unis tente
d'impulser une pression sur les talibans
et le gouvernement afghan pour accélérer
les pourparlers de paix quelle est la
stratégie de joe biden oui ok ça c'est
un peu comme cette histoire de monter
sur le dos d'un tigre les difficultés
c'est de démontrer comment faire une
retraite de troublant en gardant son
matériel encore dans son corps de
sécurité
il faut voir un partenaire se classe une
gouvernement
caliban afghane qui peuvent arranger un
bond de retraite du pays mêlant tension
le long terme c'est bien sûr pour les
états unis de sortir d'afghanistan qui
était le cimetière des empires dernière
question douglas yates joe biden à
relativiser l'afflux de migrants à la
frontière sud des états unis vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure de la politique
migratoire justement je reviens dessus
le sujet fait polémique depuis plusieurs
jours les républicains accusent joe
biden d'avoir encouragé la venue
d'exilés mexicain pourtant pas de
couverture médiatique a autorisé à la
frontière mexicaine selon le célèbre
journaliste américain john moore je cite
on passe de la tolérance zéro sous trump
os 0 access ou baden qu'est ce qu'il
faut retenir à ce sujet de sa première
conférence de pressse hier soir oui il
est en politique interne et stick un
mélange de politique domestique
domestique et internationale parce que
le frontière avec le mexique c'est en
fait le frontier avec toute l'amérique
latine et les gens qui fondent le
business de transporter les asiles les
réfugiés ne fait aucune annonce il dit
simplement qu'ils sont bienvenues aux
états unis et ça ça crée une faille dans
le temps la majorité démocrate
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de latinos temps
les étapes frontières qui n'aime pas que
les immigrés viennent et dubaï dina de
mal à garder le bois hispanique
ils essaient de mire pied dans chaque
côté et maintenant il se jette son
vice-président tca malade pour s'occuper
de ce dossier hautement sensible
politiquement
et oui les républicains vont utiliser
comme des à munitions dans leur guerre
pour les élections n'a intermédiaire
dans deux ans merci douglas y est
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeurs
américains de droit et spécialiste de
sciences politiques américaines